- You actually grew up with
quite a bit of obstacles.
What happened?
- I mean, one of my biggest hurdles
growing up in middle school,
I wore a back brace for two and
a half years, like you know,
those Romy and Michelle ones.
- In middle school?
- Yeah, seventh and eighth grade.
- Middle school already sucks.
- It was rough (laughs).
- Wow.
- It was rough, and the doctor was like,
"If you don't wear this,
you won't be able to dance."
So I was like, I have to
dance, I love dancing.
So my mom and I, we went to Macy's,
I bought clothes to go over my back brace,
and I just embraced the brace,
(audience laughing)
and I'd be like, "Punch my
stomach, it's hard as a rock."
(audience laughing)
- See this is where
your personality came in.
- Yeah, and so that helped
me build my confidence
to just kind of not allow people to,
I don't know, bring me
down or anything like that.
- Or categorize you.
(audience clapping)
- I think you're a very powerful woman,
a very powerful presence, and I love that.
And I also know you're very powerful
because you tried to start your own band
when you were a kid,
but you were too bossy?
- No, I wasn't, who told you that?
(audience laughing)
No, here's the thing.
I used my parents' printer,
like all of their ink,
you know very expensive,
(audience laughing)
and I would print out business cards
for a business I didn't have.
And I was choreographer,
and then I was looking for band mates,
and I put fliers all over
the park.
- And no one responded?
- No one called.
(audience laughing)
And so I pretended--
- I bet they're calling now.
- They should have answered that flier.
(audience laughing)
I put up a lot of them.
(audience clapping)
So yeah, I was a one-person
band for a long time.
It's interesting because my
biggest weakness growing up
was that I was gay,
and that I was different
from everyone else.
And now it's become my biggest strength
because it's empowered me to--
(audience cheering)
- I think why?
Is it because you are who you are?
- Yeah, and I think I
really feared growing up
because I was like, life is
going to be so difficult,
and people are just not
going to understand.
Going into my music career,
I was just like, if I'm
scared, everyone else will be,
so I have to embrace who I am,
I have to be the brave one,
because if I take that first step,
everyone else will follow.
And they will hopefully
(audience clapping)
grow to feel inspired and know
that they can have a good life.
They don't have to commit suicide,
they don't have to not love themselves,
they can be loved, and
it's about all these
incredible, powerful women,
and just people in general,
taking that first step and
initiative to showcase that.
- Absolutely.